you really do light up a room I'm always
so happy to see why because that's what
they say on every murder show about the
women who died what she lit up a room
and I think it's a hell did you just do
there was Krishna there was so much good
feeling here and you were riding this
huge wave and I was so happy to see you
and you took us right to your murder
this is the last day before her
retirement yeah just a few more hours if
I can get two laughs no no I
thank you yes yes I'm always very happy
to see you and I'm happy you're gonna
have a long long life now yeah you know
what's so funny
it's so funny because I I'm such a fan
of yours I love the work that you that
you do on television you really make me
laugh and I was thinking right now I
talked to you a little bit you know
off-camera and we know each other a
little bit but I don't really know what
kind of person you are right right now
the fact that you said that makes me
think that you're an anxious person do
you don't I mean that you you like go to
the dark side like oh don't say that
murdered you know I go oh yeah I'm
always thinking about death but I mean
you know a lot of people are know a lot
of people aren't always thinking about
it doctor yeah no I I do get anxious you
know the problem I have is sometimes
when people are giving me instructions
or directions things that I really need
to focus on what happens is as they as I
get ready for it they're about to give
it to me I'm like okay here it comes
this is important you better stay tuned
you better focus
oh no they're done talking No and then I
don't know how to get there and I can
ask them to repeat it but I just look
like a dimwit yeah but I'm not I'm just
focused I'm like overly overly focus
which is a sign of genius
I get tense people see me and because of
what I do for a living people always
like you know wait or whatever they'll
be like oh if I got a joke for you
when someone tells me a joke it makes me
nervous because the jokes usually
involve a lot of like okay
an astronaut takes a bologna sandwich
and he and a rabbi get into a cupcake
and I'm just like that I've got to
remember all this and I have to laugh at
the right time and then I get nervous
and then I don't listen to the joke and
then I laugh at the wrong place then
they're like that guy's an [ __ ] you
know you're not stealing jokes no I
can't I can't remember
you